each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
welcome everyone today is the last day
of Joshua shift from this internship he
comes to us from Penn State University
where after this internship he will
resume being advised by Trent Jaykar
when he joined us he was already enough
sprit and trusted computing so we were
able to put it to them to work right
away on doing personalized services in a
privacy-preserving manner thank you
hello anyway all right good you guys can
hang all right thank you for
introduction so before I start just want
to thank jay and Brian for the excellent
earn ship it was my pleasure and let's
see okay so I'll get started as Jay
mentioned this work is the I did over
the summer is on building personalized
services that also protect the users
privacy so just started all right so why
personalized services well these
services add value and relevance by
using personal information of users to
enhance whatever it is they're
delivering so a good example is targeted
advertisements I'm sure every person out
here would prefer not to receive
advertisements that are targeted towards
an age or demographic group that is not
related to them in any way like for
instance I don't receive any ads for
feminine hygiene products and I'm sure
the marketing department of these
companies also don't waste money
delivering these ads people who don't
care about it and then location-based
services search all these things benefit
from user information like search
history in order to perform optimization
on search results unfortunately the
value of these services is directly
related to how much information the
users willing to give up and in the case
of say location location based services
you're giving away your GPS coordinates
for example or with social media plugins
I can look at what my friends are
reading but they can also look what I'm
reading so so that two-way street
so as everyone's well aware of all the
recent lawsuits against large
corporations like Apple and other
companies that have been caught
collecting personal information about
users there's a desire to enable the
client or the user to be able to manage
or protect their own private information
and current regulation and upcoming
regulation like Do Not Track express
this in a legal form unfortunately it's
difficult to manage this information and
still use these services to their full
extent because you need to explicitly
release your personally identifiable
information if you wanna get the benefit
of the service in many situations and
yes okay thank you yeah I have been
looking at proposals of some lawmakers
that want to try and put this into more
of a strict framework but yes you're
absolutely correct the current existing
framework is just a suggestion this
point so yes even with the right
stronger regulation in place there's no
guarantee to the regular client that
their information is actually being
maintained properly so if microsoft says
that we will keep your information
private and then later a compromise
occurs at microsoft not necessarily
their fault information has been lost
and the user is out of luck so our goal
is to provide services to the client in
a way that's going to allow them to
protect their privacy but also still
maintain the utility of the service so
so far several approaches have existed
have been worked on and mostly they
focus on client side solutions and this
is attractive because you don't need to
modify the application that you're the
service that you're using you can opt
into it and more moreover you can verify
that it's working correctly because it's
working on your device your device
controls the release of your information
so it's very useful to be able to have
the controller there and there are
several categories of these approaches
one is to control how the data is
released so for example you can release
the information in a few skated manner
you can say instead of my GPS coordinate
to a location-based service you can give
a general region or a fuzzed location or
give out the information less often so
in like for example Google Latitude or
foursquare you may update your
information less often as opposed to
every five seconds the problem with
messing with your personal information
obfuscating it is that it reduces the
utility of the service so if you want to
say find a coffee shop near bldg 99 and
you say I'm in Washington that's a
little bit harder to service that
request and also you have to do
additional processing on your same
mobile device or whatever you're using
to get the actual result you wanted
another option is to perform the
personalization locally and this sort of
mixes with what the first category was
so services like search on the go will
collect at being of the day various
links that are popular or that related
users have looked at in the past so that
you don't have to query a server often
this has an added bonus of being
privacy-preserving because it's not
quite clear what it is the users looking
at if all the personalization is being
done on the device and likewise reprieve
and provide will try to hide the users
interests by doing personalization
locally like search optimization and
also say subscribing in the case of
provide to a large category of
advertisements and only selecting
locally the ones that are interesting to
that user and the case of this category
one of the drawbacks is that you also
have to have a very large database
locally of all the information that is
relevant to what you're looking for and
also this might be prohibitive bandwidth
prohibitive for mobile devices if you
have to use say services that are
updating constantly so you can't really
cash new information ahead of time if
you don't know it's being updated and
finally there are other approaches that
we're try to remove link ability say
with mixed networks tour or proxies this
will hide your say IP address but
there's still aspects of what you're
using the service for that may reveal
who you are so for example if you're
using a web proxy social plugins may
give away your user
for example so even if they'll your IP
address is hidden you're still in
trouble so to summarize some of the
drawbacks of the client-side approaches
are that you have an increased burden on
the client obviously higher potentially
higher bandwidth and storage
requirements more processing locally and
also messing with the information you're
giving to these services will reduce
their utility so it can we do better
than this and still ensure information
privacy our approach is to look at a
server-side approach yes it seems to
Xcode indicated on the little bit yes
you have a bit distorted awkward
instantaneous very confusing right so
this is going to be absolutely
domain-specific depending on the service
you're trying to provide we're looking
at a general approach but you're right
for services that say there is
constantly updating information you
could potentially cash a very large set
for example map tiles if you could cash
all of Washington then yeah you could
you could take care of that so like I
said our approach is to look at the
server-side solutions to the client-side
solution and the reasons for doing this
is that we get to leverage a few nice
features of being at the server that's
offering the service one is we have
massive amount of resources we have high
bandwidth connections to the services
that are offering are there being
offered to the client we also have
access to potentially aggregate
information so in the case of a
client-side solution you are siloing
everyone's information and if you have
some sort of trusted third-party running
in the server then you could potentially
aggregate this information in a safe way
so as I mentioned there's sort of two
requirements that you want to achieve if
you're going to be providing a
server-side solution because no longer
your solution is that the the clients
device and they're not able to check it
anymore and that leads into these two
requirements one is protection you need
to be able to ensure that the solution
is safe from tampering by malicious
parties and this includes not just
external Network attackers but also
physical attackers so malicious
admins working in the company or also
people who may say want to put probes
onto the device and read out whatever
keys or secrets are stored there and you
also want to be able to verify as a
client that this remote party is working
correctly on your behalf you want to be
able verify that the device you're
giving your secret information to is the
correct device and then it's running the
code that will protect your private
information so what kind of protected
modules can we create there's two major
categories that I'm dividing them into
one I'm calling software based in the
sense that the software is protecting
itself yes you assume that the client is
completely secure because the language
furniture is taking I mean I shared some
other server it's really frustrating
matter what right so our thermal here is
that the service that's offering that
that's offering out whatever to the
client is potentially untrusted so they
may be curious about what it is you're
looking for and they will gather any of
your personal information maybe sell to
third parties even if they're not
interested in doing that there may be a
rogue element within the company that
wants to say look at the personal
information that's being collected so
we're trying to come up with a solution
that will maintain the users privacy
from say these sorta tax that's right
we're assuming the client is trusted
right so the two major categories are
protected modules I'm looking at our
what I'm calling software based and
hardware based and when I say
software-based I mean that the
protections are software and are based
on software but verification is still
based in hardware so in particular we're
looking at a TPM based verification
system and there's two major related
work here one is flickr that is a system
for executing a small binary in a
trusted environment that is protected
from say that the underlying operating
system and any potential ricketts their
resident there and the flickr system
lets a remote client verify that this
protected module is running the correct
code that they want to use and that it's
on the
machine that they're they're expecting
trust Pfizer took this a little bit
further and virtualized the features of
the TPM in order to improve performance
and hyper safe is a research project
here at Microsoft that himanshu is
working on based on hyper-v which
focuses on protecting a virtual machine
running on it on the hypervisor and
separating it from a potentially
untrusted root partition the management
vm that's in charge of devices for
example to that vm on the hardware based
front there are several security
coprocessors such as the IBM crypto
processors which cost on the order of
10,000 or so dollars and these devices
are fairly beefy they have all kinds of
sensors on them they can detect changes
in temperature voltage light people
sticking probes on to them and they'll
self-destruct if you start cracking them
open or leave them on a pallet outside
of Nome Alaska and they also have fairly
powerful buses and CPUs inside for my
crypto card standards not by General PC
standards but they're pretty powerful on
the exact opposite n are the infineon
SLE chips these are essentially the
smart cards here you can see in the
middle and these devices have about a 50
megahertz coprocessor about a USB 1.0 us
and are very low power and they also
have various sensors and protections to
make sure you're not tampering with the
devices and then finally I mentioned
fpga is here because well you can do a
lot of things with these devices
including sticking security protections
on to them tamper evident sensors so I'm
looking at eyelift over the summer on
two different fronts one with the
software based solution one with the
hardware based solution we came with two
different projects in the first project
we looked at how we can design a
general-purpose platform for privacy
preserving personal services and to the
end we used hyper safe to implement
these trusted modules as protected VMs
and I'll go into that how that works and
we designed a example application that
does location-based search with bing
maps are being local actually and the
protected module will d obfuscated user
queries for them so that they don't have
to handle large amounts of results
coming back from bing and protecting the
users actual location from the untrusted
service and then the second application
we looked at is applying the hardware
security modules to hiding access
patterns and public data sets so for
example bing maps again even if you have
encrypted data sets or large public data
sets you still may want to hide exactly
what it is you're looking at so if
you're looking for driving directions
for example from your office to another
location even if you use tor say to hide
who you are Bing may see that you're
driving from building 99 to some place
so they could figure out that your
Microsoft employee and even if you
encrypted all the map tiles well they
can still get an idea of access patterns
to infer what those tiles work so we
looked at a scheme to employees these
security modules to implement various
PIR schemes in an efficient manner so
for our first project you looked at
location-based search and simply
location-based search takes your GPS
coordinates and whatever you're looking
for and gives you back a ordered list
that's from distance order from wherever
you are and if you wanted to hide your
exact location but still use the service
a strawman solution would be to say off
you skate your location say I'm in yeah
like I said Washington State and stay
billion 99 and then you'll have to parse
watch the results way back so our
solution is to leverage the protected
module to do the deification for the
client so they don't have to do all that
but still have a simple interface so
just as a simple illustration the way
that this our solution works is that the
client here is going to provide a
obfuscated of query coffee in the
Washington State area to bing maps and
along with that is going to be the
actual location of the user encrypted
along with a yeah the location that is
also signed by the users public key our
private key and this is encrypted under
the public key of our trusted module
down here
so the clients public key is also
included so that the public module can
are the private module can return the
results so this whole blob is passed a
Bing Bing returns the actual result that
was requested which was basically seven
million coffee shops in Washington state
area along with these results they're
passed to the protected module and the
other parameters the module will decrypt
the actual coordinates of the user and
then filter out the results to what the
exactly wanted bring Kurt sit under the
clients public key and pass it back to
the client yes actually we're kind of
the bottom what is good if you send
enough repeated queries incrementing the
rhythm of the search ordinal yeah very
regular but I'm glad together that makes
you do medical tests for if you do
whatever but you are wasting client
resources I'm thinking of having a
mobile phone right why why would you be
wasting client resources and well so
this is being done at Bing and sent to
the protected module locally inside a
name servers as I am able to one
right so this protected module is
actually going to reside in the data
center things data center so the query
is going to be sent to Bing and other
vertical Marty wouldn't make much okay
that's not okay so it's a little yes
okay it's not kind of time but then does
it still increase the load on the Bing
back in service yes all right several
orders of magnitude yes yes Salinas
perhaps and so it probably don't need to
obfuscate that much you probably could
say something like free City area
instead of that and you can you under
our implementation you can limit the
query to be something less than a
million results I think you've
sufficiently hit yourself in that
situation yes that information is
just doesn't that require
required to
corresponding to one particular TPM
right so in this situation yes you would
have a single module that's in charge of
that
right so our current implementation
we're using a single system we haven't
looked at how to do it under a load
balancing but then I said yes so the
privacy risk here that you're trying to
we're trying to keep the users actual
location hidden from being as always the
quarry doesn't have user ID okay how do
you know that it's my location for some
of it as opposed to someone else's the
patient well they also have your IP
address when you make requests right so
but personal belief is trusted module is
seeing some data center and it just
sends to being just exact location of it
but someone else is cooking report it
stolen cookie well-being can still see
when results are when requests are
coming into their data center so this
box is not sitting on the periphery of
the data centers within it so presumably
they can observe never traffic coming in
if you have seen algebraic because you
said that it's not a date the query and
it's going to spin into potentially
money look where it went right i mean
it's it's on the periphery of being map
service but it's still within
microsoft's like IP what there's no
question is to directly connect to the
proxy anything to say at that that idea
this is standard 0 1 dot one bottom
right and you would never know all it is
close to maintain a mapping with the
standard nap right this ppm or login is
foolish like a standard night so you're
saying something like yo yo ki well yeah
you can just have a proximate good at it
that's Roger sliprock see what I'm
solution in it requires no I'm this
rental abstract but Kane said all you do
is to cloak the ID that's it you're not
quiet again with Spencer
well so in particular we're saving the
client from having to receive all the
results back from bing if they're
providing a off you skated query so in
addition to trying to protect the users
personal information we're also trying
to save the user bandwidth and effort
having to parse through all this
requests ok DM modular whatever this
proxy will help us get simply your ideas
so ping will return only one is it and
then the first time or you will even
send it after that is that's all I I
that all the pirate word is going out of
Microsoft look exactly kind of like this
right right if you include the cookie
bar type it into the libraries are not
visible then if Ben wants to know it can
still do traffic analysis it still / the
request going to the TPM and ex-wife's
come out of the TPM so there exists a
set of proxy solutions where you can
secure your proxy and and for those who
don't even really need a TPM so it seems
like those are completely separate issue
this is for if you don't want it if you
don't want to rely on a proxy if they
want your request to go straight to me
it's a different set of solutions
I mean there are there are attacks on
various proxies so you could have if you
do it if you trust the proxy to
completely op you skate or hide where
you are where you are and be resistant
to traffic analysis and all these other
attacks on proxies then that could be a
viable solution for a particular type of
personalized service but you are
revealing that your ability 99 but for
more specific cases where you're out and
say the middle of the woods and a
request comes for driving directions for
this one house in the middle of nowhere
then even if you hide the IP address
completely you still know who is making
that request right so our threat model
here is that the data center and any for
example administrators would be
collecting the personal informations
being provided to the service in order
to customize the results and may collect
the information and the user is
concerned with the privacy of that
information so we're considering both
Network external attackers to the data
center and also administrators within
the data center
to the I'm sorry between days yes yes
that's right
the results are encrypted though so the
exact query that was requested would be
hidden
John traffic analysis
the burnout
this no they do have this problem it's
pretty start talking right there if the
size of the result for the copy shop
that in one location is different than
the size of the result for a coffee shop
and a different variation and they will
reveal but they read their known ways to
hide it wait we currently pad it to a
fixed size in response yeah we currently
repair our responses to a fixed size to
deal with that particular
ok
right so how we implemented this system
we use typer safe to create our
protected module what hyper safe does it
provides a feature called emancipation
normally VM is running in hyper-v have a
root partition which is responsible for
virtualizing devices for example setting
up the VM and it always has access
normally under hyper-v to certain pages
of memory of the VM so under if we're
going to verify our protected module we
also have to verify a large potentially
buggy TCB that includes the root vm the
root partition so what emancipation lets
us do is the vm is the memory pages that
are shared between the vm and the root
partition are separated there unmapped
and the VMS the are trusted module or
the being that we're loading it a hash
of it is taken before it is executed so
in a sense this is like a virtual dr TM
if you're familiar with that or virtual
virtual boot environment essentially a
measured boot environment so what remote
verifier has to do is just verify that
the hypervisor code is trustworthy and
that the vm itself is trustworthy and no
longer it has to verify the root
partition so on top of this system we
are then implementing a protective
module as what as a very small minimal
execution environment this is our tmk
we're using to implement that so the TM
k is is essentially a program that
stresses the various features of the
hypervisor and what we did if you took
this TM k which is roughly around
hundred kilobytes which has no OS are
very crude memory manager support built
into it and we implemented our trusted
service inside of this which is going to
do the personalization or the client and
the trust of module receives inputs from
the untrusted service through a shim
which runs in the untrusted root
partition and this is presented on a
single specially assigned shared memory
region for the vm
so in order to verify this whole system
we have this following process hyper
safe when its first booted it uses the
measured launched environment which will
record the the code that's used to boot
the entire process so this includes the
firmware well actually now this includes
the the boot loader and the hypervisor
itself and the this code is stored
inside the TPM and the TPM also will
generate an RSA key pair for the hyper
safe hypervisor and this key parrot is
then well that the secret key is sealed
under the actual measurements of the
binaries that were loaded at boot time
and it's also signed by the TPM signing
key so only a particular only the
particular hyper safe binaries that were
used to boot into the system can
actually decrypt this key later at a
later date so we have a particular
version of hyper safe it boots we
generate a key the TPM seals under that
particular version of hyper safe and
later if it boots into a modified
version of hyper say for malicious one
it won't be able to access this key
because it's protected by the physical
TPM then once the hyper safe hypervisor
is loaded it will measure and load the
UTM k and it will also generate RSA key
pair for this protected module and will
sign the public key with the DMK's
actual code hash and then it will
provide the secret key to the trust
module and put both of these public keys
available on a public website so that a
client can obtain them and know which
key to encrypt the query under when it
sends it to the trusted module and you
can also inspect the actual code that
was used to boot into that system so I
can see if it's trustworthy or not is
there any questions before I go past
this it's a little little convoluted
okay okay
so I'd like to give you a brief demo of
the application we created
okay so let's see what i have here i
have two different machines this machine
is running the windows phone emulator
and this code is the client code for
interacting with the protected module
the protected module is our tmk i
mentioned before running on a separate
machine that is running hyper safe and
there is a shim program running on that
machine that is that the web service
that's implementing our our untrusted
service communicates to so what will
happen is the client will send a request
to the web service the web service will
essentially make queries to Bing to get
back the results pass these results to
our tmk it will do the
operationalization GFX gets back the
response and then sends it to our client
I'd probably want to go through three
levels of indirection to remote desktop
into my other remote desktop through
this remote desktop so I'll just show
you the client all right
okay so this is our trusted Search
application and we can provide a query
that we want to search for so I'm hungry
for pizza and then we'll get our
location and then obfuscation level here
what this does is essentially perturbed
your current location to Bing gives it
random offsets and then will also
increase the radius search sighs I can
increase that let's go to five and then
this number of results we can look for
so will happen here is it takes a little
bit to load right okay so these are the
nearest ten pizza joints around here
yeah it's a little little slow over
remote desktop but yeah these are the
various locations and you can see there
they're ordered by distance from the
user so I mean looking up phonebook
directory information is exciting in its
own right but you get the basic idea of
how this works so on the back end
actually 100 queries have been recent
retrieved and they are from a
essentially over near the OTC pickup
spot instead of here so they're a little
perturbed but it's been relocated by our
trusted module to this actual location
so there's not too much exciting going
on here unfortunately but yeah that's
the the demo any questions
okay so yes so yeah so the functionally
verifies the results that gets back from
the supervised Lestat usual so I mean
you said the hyper safe generates these
cues and these are all chained back to
TM that's pretty okay that's great yeah
so it'll be signed better to TPM sunny
key and then that key can be verified
through either the platform key or you
can use other methods like directed
anonymous attestation to verify that key
and then these keys yeah yeah Microsoft
for example could have a pki internally
for all of its devices which I believe
it does have okay I don't as an intern I
can't get access to the key fobs to
remotely access the machine so going on
to our second project we looked instead
of using our software based approaches
with hyper safe we looked at using our
hardware security modules so to give you
some motivation here we're looking at
hiding access patterns to say large set
of public data for example bing maps and
oftentimes the exact what you're looking
for reveals information about who you
are like I mentioned before if you're
making requests for driving directions
you're giving away information about
where you're potentially located so
encryption is a natural way of hiding
this information from untrusted servers
so such as a cloud storage device but
even if the data is encrypted at the
pattern in which you access the
information may reveal exactly what is
under what is encrypted on the system
especially if some additional knowledge
is given about what the data may be so
there are various schemes for retrieving
private retrieving this encrypted
information to hide your access patterns
and when these schemes are typically
called private information retrieval and
as a simple example consider the Bing
Maps example I gave before so this tile
here is level 17 of the Bing map tile
database level 17 is roughly a 100 by
100 meter tile give or take a few
hundred meters so a typical a trivial
PIR solution for hiding what exactly
you're looking for is to access every
element in the database that's obviously
infeasible for Bing Maps because there's
60 billion tiles roughly we didn't do
get an idea what our data set looked
like we did some experiments to evaluate
how many tiles are there and this is
just the last few levels of the database
as you can see 17 and 19
roughly where everyone looks at when you
actually look at driving directions this
is yeah more or less so after 19 the
information available from satellites is
so small that there's not really
anything there and everyone pretty much
doesn't look at the Continental size map
tiles so this is where most of our
information is concerned so our analysis
looks at this stupid this data set here
in particularly particular level 17 so
how can we do something better than the
trivial solution one option is using
oblivious ram so oblivious ram does
gives you a sub linear amortized cost
for doing private information retrieval
on a database i'm not going to go over
the entire construction for oblivious
ram there are various different schemes
but to give you an intuition of what's
going on and if you saw Marianas talk
you probably already earlier in the
summer you probably know about this but
the basic idea is that information is
encrypted under different keys for each
epoch and the information is retrieved
in such a way that each record is only
requested once so that the untrusted
server sees only random accesses to a
single records within the database and
once this all the records have either
been touched or your your cash that
you're working on has been filled you'll
reshuffle everything under a new
encryption key will Reaper mute
everything and so there are numerous
schemes for doing this with different
efficiencies some are better than others
oftentimes the worst case for space time
for retrieving a single record can get
really bad especially if you've hit your
your budget you need to reshuffle
everything so we need to look at a
solution that makes sure that the
worst-case scenario is very good so that
we can actually have an online service
so we're considering here at new model
in the under traditional models for over
mu you typically have a single client
interacting with a single server maybe
two servers and all the clients that are
interacting with this untrusted server
are typically non-cooperative parties so
they're not working together to improve
the performance of over a min anyway and
this doesn't allow for parallel parallel
retrieval power parallelism to improve
performance program anyway so we're now
considering a model where we have lots
of clients all working together to serve
a single goal because our trusted
modules essentially conserve a single
client with high parallelism so we'd
like to be able to come up with a scheme
or modify existing schemes that will
leverage the hundreds of thousands of
coprocessors coprocessors that are in
the data center to improve the
performance of our PIR scheme we'd also
like to reduce the overall worst-case
access time and hopefully shuffling if
possible so just to pay for anyone who's
not familiar with Aram just to give you
a brief idea of how one of the schemes
to work this is one of the simpler
algorithms often called the square root
algorithm that gold reckon ostrosky
presented so the basic idea here is the
old random data structure has two levels
the top level is typically called a
cache and this second level is your
entire data set so a client wanting to
retrieve a particular record and
remember this all these elements have
been encrypted and / muted under a
usually pseudo-random permutation so if
a client wants to retrieve a particular
record first yes to check this cash
doesn't have the record so you'll scan
through the top level if it is found
he'll make a note of that so if it was
not there he will actually go and
retrieve the record and add it to the
cash if it was in the cache then he will
retrieve a dummy record which has been
added to the data set or in some schemes
will retrieve just a red record so as
you can see over time you'll have your
cash fill up with requests that and
you're only ever retrieving one record
once if it's been requested a second
time you'll retrieve some different
records that hasn't requested or a dummy
record so once the cash has been filled
then you will need to Reaper mute
everything in your data set and that's
where a large cost comes in because
there's in bing maps a 60 billion tiles
you have to reshuffle
so our goal like I said earlier is to
support multiple users that want to
interact with this database and we want
to minimize the worst-case access time
so our basic idea is is that we want to
minimize or we want to maximize the
number of requests we can perform before
shuffle is necessary so increase our
cache size unfortunately few increase
the cache size forever then you have to
linearly scan the entire cache size and
that would take too long so we want to
increase this cache size effectively
without actually increasing the access
time and we want to perform if possible
our request and shuffle in parallel so
say have a replicated data set that
would be shuffling in the background why
we're doing our request and then we can
swap over this would be the ideal
scenario so you don't have to wait for a
shuffle hooker so our approach is to use
thousands of these inexpensive SLE
infineon coprocessors the ones I
mentioned earlier that have about two
dollars apiece to do all this PIR scheme
and the coprocessors because they're all
working on a single data set unencrypted
under the same key we can serve multiple
clients without the clients having to
manage their own keys for encrypting the
data they'll just have to negotiate with
the coprocessors so our initial scheme
for paralyzing the square root algorithm
I showed you earlier if you consider
having see coprocessors here are
probably 100,000 if possible each with a
cache size of K and a single master
coprocessor which we will select in
round-robin order to make sure the cache
is stay balanced we will all the
coprocessors will scan their caches in
parallel whenever request comes in and
for each for each of the co processors
that are not the master view the first
two lines here we have returned value is
going to be essentially the difference
of two different p RFS and what we're
working on whether working on is
creating essentially all the shares of a
single record location that the interest
server will then eventually retrieve and
we want to hide exactly which record is
being
requested so the server can't tell if
it's a dummy or a actual record because
we don't want to reveal that a
previously requested record was
available so the first line is going to
be the the difference of the two PRS for
the current coprocessor in the next co
presser in coprocessor in the circular
ring and then the second line is if the
coprocessor does detect that one of the
records is in its cache it will perturb
the result a bit so that it will not
trust the server we retrieve a dummy
value instead of the correct value and
finally the master record provides the
actual address of the requested record
so if none of the other coprocessors
have detected the requested record it
will simply request from the untrusted
server the correct value if it was found
it will perturb it to the requests a
dummy value instead so the sir so that
in this case we have all of our
coprocessors working parallel they don't
need to communicate with each other to
use the untrusted server to do the
retrieval for it for it so then this
response is sent back to the master
coprocessor in addition all the slave
coprocessors are going to write back an
additional file to the untrusted server
and so we'll use this as an opportunity
to pass the requested record to the
master coprocessor so it doesn't have to
receive it from all of the slave
coprocessor simultaneously so under this
under the scheme here if the record is
present in the cache of one of the
coprocessors they will explore this with
a PRF of its coprocessor ID along with
the next coprocessor ID and if it has
not been found it will simply be a bunch
of zeros X sword with the those values
so these are all combined explore
together on the untrusted server if the
record was not present any other
coprocessors it will essentially be a
bunch of zeros that can be extracted by
the master coprocessor when it X orders
its own PRF value if it was present then
it will get the value back and it can
return that to the client
any questions on this
quest again one sec you say it so if
you're returning a fake file what
happens that because the client
so the client will get the requested
tile what this team is doing is its
hiding from the server whether or not
the requested i was asked access
previously so if the tile wasn't in any
of the caches it will be retrieved from
the server and the master node will send
that back to the client and if it wasn't
the server if it was wasn't one of the
caches it will be combined into the
second record that sent to the master
node and it can be extracted from the
combined explore blob by just simply
exhorting his own PRF value here into
that so the actual record if it was
president the caches will be received by
the master node and it wasn't the caches
it will be retrieved by the server from
the first round okay so under the
configuration of the SLE seventy-eights
we were doing some investigation into
that we found that we could get assuming
an ideal a bus speed of the USB one
point no bus we can get about a 70
millisecond response time from the
entire level 17 bing maps database now
this is an ideal bus speed the devices
probably won't be able to sustain the
complete USB one point no bus speed but
we're looking into how we can get a
better performance on that now the issue
comes when you have to actually shuffle
the entire data set and we're exploring
various ways of doing this under the
current schemes that people have looked
at they typically use some sort of
sorting network such as a bionic sorting
network or other bachelor sortie
networks to implement the sorting and
the advantage of these sources that they
maintain the oblivious property because
the sorting is predetermined ahead of
time so you don't have to basically none
of the sorting is done by examining the
values of the records it's just other
than a simple comparison of two records
so we're looking at a Waxman permutation
network that what sorry we're looking at
maximum permutation network in order to
improve the efficiency of the sorting
currently I can show you
yeah so sorry the axes are missing a few
values at the bottom here but the basic
idea is that if you have say a hundred
thousand coprocessors on the far right
again with the ideal USB one point O bus
we can do sorting on level 17 in about
mmm 50 50 hours or so that's probably
way too long to actually do the scheme
but we are looking at ways of improving
this one option is to use a hybrid
coprocessor approach so as I mentioned
before those IBM crypto cards which are
have a much faster bus they have a pci
express bus which is on the order of
gigabytes our gigabits transfer rate so
if we can employ those to do the sorting
and use the sles to do the requests then
we might be able to match the
performance I don't have the chart
included here but if we had say just a
USB to point out bus on these devices we
would cut this down to about a half an
hour to sort the entire data set with a
with less than 50,000 coprocessors so
mostly we're bus limited at this point
but as these coprocessors would improve
in performance and the cost comes down
we should be able to do this in a
reasonable amount of time so as I
mentioned next step is to look at hybrid
approaches also looking at different
device configurations so for example
those FPGA as I mentioned earlier if we
can configure them to be as physically
resistant as the more expensive trips
out coprocessors then we can get much
more performance systems and yeah those
are the main the key points there right
so in conclusion we looked at two
different approaches for building
privacy-preserving services in the data
center the first one we looked at was a
platform for deploying services that
would do the personalization on the half
behalf of the user interacting with an
untrusted service and we implemented a
example of that with location-based
search and the second project we looked
at was how we can change the a ramp
model to try and improve parallelism and
get better performance in a real world
scenario
and I'll take any question feel like
this being mad
I'll trust
bring in some locations I understand
love cases
kitchen itself may not be so
right so we did look at a few other
examples we use bing maps here because
it was the most straightforward to
implement and we had interesting
information about the data set itself so
other services we looked at were
location sharing among yeah you're
different your friends for example so if
you want to use untrusted service to
coordinate with friends your current
location you want to keep that hidden
and without having to involve key
management among all different friends
another example of a service we looked
at it was plagiarism detection so for
example if you have a bunch of
conferences that are submitting around
the same time and you want to be able to
check that none of the papers are
plagiarisms that they've been
simultaneously submitted to multiple
conferences but you don't want to reveal
what those submissions are to anyone we
can implement a service like this that
could receive the two results and check
and respond whether or not a plagiarism
was detected another example the service
would be working on the aggregate
information I mentioned earlier so if
you can have essentially a large
database that's only accessible by our
trusted module it can collect a great
information and provide say prob
recommendations for netflix for example
without revealing whose search history
to the revealing the search history to
the untrusted service so working on
encrypted search for example is on the
exam system
okay yeah
so the hyper safe system that we're
working on it has a lot of similarities
to the trust visor system one of the
differences though is we're able to
still communicate with the untrusted
service so we can control the exact
pages are being shared between the
untrusted service and the trusted
service and this allows us to actually
implement a shim to communicate with the
trusted module so because we are
communicating their with the outside
world through a continuous manner you
will have to design the trusted module
to be able to resist any sort of
malicious inputs so in that regard it's
a more performant way of implementing
something like Flickr where you would
have our isolated execution environment
running our trusted model in terms of
the let's see the other services I was
talking about where the like repo for
example reprieve I'm sorry so reprieve
as I mentioned earlier is doing all the
personalization locally on the device so
it's going to be limited by the amount
of information you have present on the
device and what kind of information you
can glean from just the user itself so
if you want to get other information
like correlate with similar users you're
not going to able to do that locally
without retrieving that information and
coordinating with other users to share
their information and establishing an
aggregate and search on the go for
example also uses aggregate information
but that's going to require subscribing
to an aggregate which necessarily
reveals which I great you belong to
yes
that probably sexy
magic episode also
Reserve has privacy preservation
and I'll make it
I think the best way to look at is that
the private the projected module in the
data center is acting essentially as the
client would act if it had all the
bandwidth to communicate with the
untrusted service in exam in our example
for you that the location-based search
so the client would be able to perform a
few skated query get back thousands of
results and then do the deal right but
this is a trusted proxy it's going to be
performing the D obfuscation for the
client it's not necessarily missing just
re rabbit in the Greek list because
there was its opening it reveals
to ask for aids clinics near Brian's
house then no matter how you wrote that
still going to visit us
where is the solution dude escort aids
clinics in Washington State and then
they trusted proxy
filter down to this is near my house
so far you could let's because all the
pins result went
right you could also do an approximate
I my discipline question is can you do
all of these without trusting you can do
it by yourself in this example if you
only need a proxy is it the whole point
of TPM is to make sure that you can't
to do the D occupation for you so
basically TPM yes
so we have an entity working in the data
center for the user and you can check
that it was correct
that's right and because these modules
are very small like I said about a
hundred kilobytes it should be possible
to instantiate thousands of these over
say Hydra network p.m. hostess
TBI margin
there are many users
it's fun
you're saying this is your TV etymology
would have the notional multiple users
for the BMS the model users you many
different user
IC H so this is why we're including the
clients public key and the query so that
it can be stateless essentially the TPM
is not involved in handling the result
specifically so we designed this so that
there is no interactive at a station
protocol essentially it's a secure boot
setup if you did have to attest it would
be a serious attestation issue at the
handle
how can you do to extend this trusty
module two
act like house of passage trust
I want my request
so you would have to trust the module to
be able to keep the two requests
separate
you couldn't senshi eight per user team
pays is the eye and someone else has
same public
so that the trustee module
something so there's no authentication
right so the responses I given back in
this situation are not secret in the
sense that someone else at the secret
key giving up that information
not quite that but I see if you're
saying the situation